for the first time since surviving
severe covet 19 last march matthew
cardinal went back to the regina
hospital that saved his life it was
hard for me to go to the hospital it was
very hard going to a place where dying
basically
it was traumatizing left with long-haul
symptoms his future with the virus
remains unclear as so many others moved
to put this pandemic in the past the
direction we're going in now
i wouldn't say we're nearing the end but
i i think there are many ways in which
we can see the end that's not
necessarily the end of the world we
spend every day of our lives living with
viruses that once caused pandemics
influenza the 1918 spanish flu was the
deadliest pandemic on record but thanks
to herd immunity and medication it
fizzled out in the late 1980s there was
hiv aids but modern treatments have made
it a manageable disease
2009's h1n1 outbreak is often called the
forgotten pandemic thanks to technical
advancement surveillance and treatments
that quelled it so quickly montreal
microbiologist donald vin says really
only smallpox and possibly sars which
hit toronto hard in the early 2000s have
been eradicated what's likely going to
happen with stars cov2 may be similar to
what we saw with the 1918
influenza which is that
there was a peak amount of activity over
a certain number of years that
eventually decreased through a variety
of both viral biology and medicine and
public health measures leaving us to
coexist with covid to get there experts
say we can't repeat history we need to
focus on our failing health care systems
and build up capacity communicate public
health measures clearly to further avoid
pandemic fatigue put in place proper
data collection which we fail to
prioritize and continue to vaccinate
test contact trace and surveil as much
as many people want to believe this is
over this is not over
there will be subsequent waves the
question here is how and to what extent
will those impact us in canada the
answer may lie in what we've learned and
how we respond as a collective
jamie morocco global news toronto